joining us now is cbs news senior
political analyst and 60 minutes
correspondent john dickerson
we're happy to tell you that he's in the
studio today john welcome we are not
we are not relegating you to the kids
table we're just practicing social
distancing
we're very glad you are here john and
it's good to be near you gail
all right did i detect sarcasm john
we're getting down to the nitty and the
gritty so
the final campaigns what does this tell
us what does this final lap tell us
about what each candidate is doing
well the first thing it tells us which
we didn't need to know that how
important uh
pennsylvania is all the candidates will
be there so harris pence
biden and trump will all be in
pennsylvania the turf if you look at the
battleground map the
simplest way to think about it is this
is turf the president is defending that
he won in 2016.
his travel is all about the places he's
trying to defend what's interesting is
that one trip joe biden is taking into
ohio
that's that's basically biden going into
the deeper redder part of the map
they must be seeing something there or
they're foolhardy at the end
but that is quite interesting and then
the other important thing is they're
they're all trying to turn out the vote
on election day
there's no persuasion going on it'll be
interesting to see what president obama
does for the black vote with democrats
in his travel
john the president says we should know
the results on election night and
has reportedly told people that he'll
declare victory
if it looks like he's ahead what do you
make of the president saying that
well i've spent some time talking to
national security officials in the
administration and also uh secretaries
of state and election officials in the
states and what they say
is that when you've got an election
where they are boarding up windows in
american cities you want
forces of all at all levels to be
tamping things down not to be calling
the u.s election system
into question so in that environment you
have
perhaps the most vocal voice the most
popular the person with the biggest
platform
calling the american election into
question so the president
is at odds with what his national
security officials are trying to do it's
much actually like
he's at odds with his health officials
with respect to the pandemic
i know john you were in arizona recently
and cbs news as you know is calling it a
toss-up state what other battleground
states are you looking at
well arizona is particularly interesting
because it is a booming state it has the
county
maricopa county at the center of all of
our conversations on election night the
biggest county in arizona is the fastest
growing county
in the country it's the biggest county
donald trump won in 2016. and
he's got so many supporters there but
there's also a rift in the party there
and the reason arizona is interesting is
it
that's where the country is heading to
be more like a state like
arizona more diverse and so if donald
trump can win there it means he's
winning into
america where it's headed this election
is about
who's the candidate of the future and
who's the candidate uh of the past
in part and so arizona is interesting
that way i'm really interested in east
coast states that report their results
early
so that's florida and north carolina
they've been counting and tabulating
processing votes early
john both candidates spending uh their
last hours in pennsylvania hotly
contested state a key state
uh the absentee ballot deadline was
extended there there's a legal battle
over it what's the significance of that
well it the legal battle is it means
they're the secretary of state in
pennsylvania has said they will
count those votes that that come in uh
after election day the
the uh the problem the question is
counting them and then holding on to
them
adding them to the total will they be
interrupted by a legal fight
uh so that's still a bit of a question
mark there's supposed to be more
guidance coming from the secretary of
state i believe today
uh on what happens but uh what it could
mean is that those votes
get counted even though they come in
later the president as we mentioned has
been saying the election has to be
determined on election day
that's never happened uh so it's just
another way in which pennsylvania is
going to be a sticky state
in addition to the fact that it takes
them a long time to count votes many
people worry john about november third
the day after election
you know the thinking is country's going
to be deeply divided it already is
what do you think each candidate needs
to do to unite the country the candidate
needs to unite the country the same way
a president does which is to speak to
the people who are not in your base
this is a key quality of the president
to understand their needs to hear them
and say i hear you
and not add just a bunch of gasoline to
the floor
that can be ignited with people whose
emotions are running high
all right john dickerson thank you very
much see in a couple hours
john and i are part of the cbs news team
bringing you election results in a prime
time special
we've been working all weekend and
tomorrow night cbs news 2020 election
night america decides
nora o'donnell is leading the coverage
so we'll be joining her along with
margaret brennan and ed o'keefe
starts at seven o'clock eastern six
central and will go as late as it goes
right here on cbs